You should be an engineer.
I'm a Negro woman.
I'm not gonna entertain the impossible.
I'm standing beneath a spaceship.
We are living the impossible!
The IBM data processing system.
We have to know how to program it.
Attagirl.
NASA doesn't commission females for the engineer program.
Every time we have a chance to get ahead,...
I would like to attend today's briefing.
There is no protocol for women attending.
...they move the finish line.
You all should be thankful you have jobs at all.
I don't even know if I can keep up in that room.
You're better with the numbers than anyone in that cabinet.
You've been gone for 300 hours.
It felt like it to me, too.
You're never where I need you to be, where the hell do you go every day?
The colored bathroom is a mile away.
We all get to the peak together or we don't get there at all.
More than 50 million people are watching this launch.
John, the IBM is wrong.
Let's get the girls to check the numbers.
My gals are ready.
We can do the work.
Colonel Glenn?
It's good to know NASA hasn't given up on good old-fashioned brain power.
The Friendship 7 has experienced some sort of a malfunction.
There's a real fireball outside, it's getting a little hot in here.
We're in the fight of our lives, people!